our next speaker is Kevin as well he's
come from MIT Media Lab where he runs
the sculpting evolution group there he
is a very intriguing title which is open
local and obligated
all right so first of all as an
evolutionary engineer and
biotechnologists
is my business to make pigs fly and we
have been approaching this problem from
a perspective that attempting to ensure
that the FDA or any other federal
regulatory authority or really anyone
involved in politics whatsoever and
attempt to get the existing legal system
to give some kind of public acceptance
and support and validity of what you're
doing is frankly a fool's errand that is
you have to abide by the regulations
because they are there they are legal
you must comply with them but you should
never go to the FDA and rely on its
evaluation process to win you public
support for your projects that is just
not how this works but I'm also not
particularly interested in any
particular biotechnology product that is
I'm interested in changing the culture
of how we do science in these areas and
not so much just because I'm frankly
because I'm all that concerned about
particular marginalized groups and
hearing voices and so on but because
technology is becoming increasingly
powerful and we are not necessarily wise
enough to use it in every case so I
don't trust myself to make a wise
decision with any of the technologies
that we develop which is why we go and
ask other people everyone so open and
responsive science is especially
important of course in any project that
seeks to alter the common environment
because we all share the common
environment and that means that we need
to at least tell other people what we
are thinking of doing before we even
begin experiments so this is difficult
right because every incentive in science
points against it if you share your
brilliant idea
you are basically inviting some larger
better funded lab with spare hands to
come in steal it get it working first
with their extra money and manpower
advantage publish and then they get 100%
of the credit and you get none that is a
cultural problem an institutional
problem that we need to change
because if you don't tell people what
you're doing in advance you're not
actively inviting concerns and criticism
at a time that could be meaningful in
terms of changing how the project works
Jeanne drive is a particular concern of
mine not only because of a certain moral
responsibility when it comes to the
CRISPR based form but because with a
gene Drive system at least be
self-sustaining invasive kind that can
spread forever if you even decide to
build one of those in the laboratory you
are running the risk that it will fly
out the window and if it does they will
start to spread at least if you're
foolish enough to run it in a when your
laboratory is within the endemic range
of the target species which no one
should ever do but people do and your
decision to even go ahead and build that
in the lab means that you are performing
an experiment that could affect other
people and if you don't tell them that
you're doing that in advance you are
actively denying them a voice in a
decision that could affect them and
frankly that's wrong so we have to
change the incentives and there's only
so much you can do in terms of changing
how industry does things it's possible
primarily through changing cultural
attitudes and beliefs but really I'm
most concerned about academics and
that's because academics really don't
appreciate public input most of us we
tend towards shall we say liking to
retreat into our caves or our gorgeous
ivory towers as the case may be and
pursuing our own pet projects and
systems independent of all that blather
and fuss out there that's known as
politics for very good reasons because
politics is the mind killer if what you
care about is the intellectual life of
the mind you want to stay as far away
from anything political as possible but
the reality is that what you want to do
is change the world then there is no
choice but to engage in politics and so
what we need to do if we want to make
academics actively share their plans
before they perform the experiments even
in a small subfield such as gene Drive
we have to get the journals for example
to require experimental pre-registration
in order to eventually publish your work
if you get if we get the leading
journals to say
no we will not publish your work unless
you pre-registered it on in one of these
venues the experiments that you're going
to perform the safeguards you are going
to use and we won't publish it then
watch all the academics jump to
pre-register same deal with the funders
we'll give you money to perform the
experiments but only if you're open with
them well then we're going to be open
and it's not that most scientists and
I've talked to for essentially everyone
in the gene Dr feel it's not that anyone
objects to being open it's just we're
all afraid of being scooped and that but
if we can require everyone to do the
right thing then that fear basically
goes away it's a collective action
problem it's everyone or no one for the
most part with some exceptions the last
one we're actually looking at is
intellectual property which is probably
not typically considered the friend of
most people who are concerned with the
public system like he was originally was
originally conceived to ensure that the
work was made open so that others could
build on it but of course you can't
actually get anything useful out of a
patent they're actually written to avoid
that but why not use intellectual
property to require openness in terms of
experiments and gene graphs that's all
we're looking for can we create a patent
pool using our CRISPR gene Drive patents
and possibly other relevant patents that
would only give research licenses to
institutions that pledge to make all of
their research open from before they
perform those experiments and because my
group is at the Media Lab where we don't
exactly suffer from the same incentives
governing everyone else we started to
just go ahead and pre-register all of
our experiments involving gene drives we
just write up an article exactly as we
would for a journal publication and we
post a preprint on bio archive just like
we normally do but we do it before we
run the experiments and just detail what
we're planning to do and what the
safeguards are
we also have a project that doesn't
involve gene drive where we're still
open many of these same rules the idea
is round here tick-borne disease is a
serious problem it's something that
people care about it's one of those
things if you talk to the typical person
on the street they will know somebody
who has been afflicted in this area and
it's something that people would like
more solutions for so this is an area
where biotechnology might actually be
worthwhile engineered salmon maybe not
tick-borne disease yes
so it's worst on the islands of
Nantucket and Martha's Vineyard and our
idea is since most ticks are infected by
white-footed mice if we could immunize
the mice then you would break the cycle
of transmission tics would no longer be
infected people wouldn't get disease and
we can immunize mice without actually
using any foreign DNA this is totally
and completely 100% irrelevant from a
scientific standpoint there is natural
gene flow between all wild populations
the notion of a species is a totally
confabulated concept that is that we
adopt even in science just because we
like to put things in mental boxes all
sweet potatoes or GMOs the cow genome is
25% snake but all of that is immaterial
because people out there citizens in
these communities they care and so if
they don't want foreign genes in their
mice then we won't put foreign genes in
their mice because they're the ones in
control they're the ones who live there
what's more this is an example of trying
to make the smallest possible change
that will solve the problem now you
might say how on earth is engineering an
entire wild population of white-footed
mice the smallest possible change that
could solve the problem well the way
we're doing it is we're taking the
adaptive immune response the evolved
antibodies that some mice evolved when
we expose them to the pathogen taking
those antibody encoding genes pulling
out the most protective ones and
inserting those into the mouse genome so
that future generations of mice can
inherit them so the mice also have a
genome size we just had them sequenced
in the billions
so you're introducing 10,000 bases of
DNA that came from another Mouse into
all the mice that's a pretty tiny change
on the scale of say spraying and care
asides to kill the ticks which also kill
all sorts of other to
in fact that might actually be the
smallest possible change and the reason
why we're working with the islands is
because any time you're engineering any
complex system doesn't matter what it is
you can't always predict all the side
effects you start small you see what
happens and you scale up if warranted so
we're starting with a uninhabited island
again only if the communities of
Nantucket and Martha's Vineyard which
now have steering committees in charge
of the project want us to go forwards
then we will release mice on a small
island perhaps a thousand or so mice
that has a population of 1,000 or so
native mice and through standard mixing
no gene drive the native my sole take up
the genes they will otherwise be
genomically matched so the only
difference will be those Mouse
antibodies and then we'll see what
happens and if an independent assessment
committee like says this looks good and
the communities vote and decide to
proceed then possibly you might see my
son Nantucket in the vineyard but albeit
not until 2024 so this is the other
thing as I mentioned Islanders have
steering committees now that are
actually in charge of the project not us
we actually request the community
guidance before we did any research
experiments funding funding requests
anything and we're have a data safety
monitoring board that's being assembled
that will do all the independent
assessment because just as you should
never trust the person who proposed the
hypothesis to test it which may be
perhaps a reform we should try in
science sometime you really don't want
the people who develop the technology to
be doing the assessment of whether how
it works and again this would be also
independent of FDA or anything like that
although the data would of course be
submitted to them too and we have been
working
we have did consult with the FDA and
Fish and Wildlife before beginning this
project because you need them on the
same page we have to jump through those
hoops but those are hoops the point is
the communities in control and where
again we're starting local and we're
going to scale up only if the community
wishes and this is what I'd like to see
for all projects of this type pick
something that people definitely want to
see don't even bother introducing a new
technology unless there is a really
obvious benefit that is obvious to
everyone which by the way means no
agriculture it as bur
you should never ever ever introduce a
new technology in the area of
Agriculture because it's invisible to
most people here's the problem with with
these rules start local well Jim shows
you the animation last night this thing
sells scales you cannot run a field
trial you cannot introduce it anywhere
in the endemic environment without
having it spread probably to every
population and if it wouldn't do it
naturally well people will move it how
many trolls are there on the Internet
lots more than enough to move a few mice
or mosquitoes or anything else and if
there's economic reason to do so they
will Australia loves engineering viruses
to wipe out their cute bunny rabbits New
Zealand decided that when the Khalifah
virus got out of control in Australia
they didn't want it New Zealand New
Zealand farmers smuggled it in any way
through the tightest biocontrol
restrictions in the world do you think
you can stop that just because it's a
gene drive not going to happen so we
just can't do this like malaria maybe
that might be a big enough problem that
it would be worth that all enough
African countries could all all decide
to come together and agree they want to
do it maybe even without a field trial
but for any lesser problem it's just not
going to happen which means we need
local gene drive systems we don't need
this for the white-footed mice because
there are few enough mice on Nantucket
and the vineyard that is it's feasible
to grow up and release a hundred
thousand engineered mice it's not
feasible to do more than that so we need
some form of amplification effect we
don't want it to spread forever so my
group is developing Davy Drive systems
that could do this and the basic idea is
for the simpler version it's called the
Davey field is that you split up the
components of the drive system so you
have these are the targeting
instructions telling the drive system
where to cut this is the CRISPR nucleus
that does the cutting this is the cargo
team you want to spread as long as you
has at least one genetic element telling
it to cut here then it will convert the
organism from a heterozygote at this
locus to a homozygote but there's
nothing causing these two drives meaning
that drive only occurs as long as you
still have some and those are diluted
out
so if you start with an organism that
has say four copies made it to wild-type
on average the offspring you're gonna
have to made a do-while type again those
offspring you're gonna have one all the
offspring of that mating are still going
to inherit your cargo but these guys are
now I would have extra targeting
elements so you don't see drive anymore
it just stops literally it just runs out
of genetic fuel and stops but depending
on how many copies you put in then you
can get an amplification effect so you
can release compared over a few
organisms an effective broader
population but even that is not good
enough because like it or not we humans
do compartmentalize things in boxes and
we do these things called draw political
boundaries and so you can imagine that
one community might decide they want to
say immunize their local Mouse
population here and the neighboring
community will not what if New Haven
wants to and Hartford doesn't you're
going to just tell them I stand not
cross the boundary though we can to some
extent do that we believe by by
essentially making the gene drive
democratic there seems to be a popular
word around here how do you have a gene
vote in a quorum well if you do some
clever tricks where you're swapping
absolutely essential genes where you
need two copies and then they're swapped
in position meaning that when you have a
mating event there's a 50% chance of
inheriting either one that means that
anyone who inherits only one copy
essentially one swapped in one wild-type
they're toast in other words it's bad to
be a hybrid of engineered and wild what
that means is in an engineered
population it actually favors the
engineered alleles because when you're
mostly mating with other engineered
alleles and so all of their offspring
are fine in the wild type similarly it's
better to mate with wild type because I
know a Roth spring are fine but it
penalize does anything that does the
mixing and so the Daisy quorum effect in
effect ensures that this turns on only
after you run out of data elements so in
other words you introduce your Daisy
organisms in the environment it spreads
your alteration through the target
population as soon as it runs out of
data elements it becomes bad to mate
with wild type and so you basically
block
in flow between the engineer and wild
populations thereby confining it to the
city that wants it and keeping it out of
the city that doesn't highway
theoretical pie-in-the-sky
except this is entirely based on crisper
and crisper is magic lastly what we
really hope to do given that sooner or
later someone is going to screw up
involving probably fruit flies and
released any highly invasive gene Drive
system that's going to spread around the
world and cause disastrous headlines
scientists accidentally convert entire
wild population or entire species to
GMOs is CRISPR to blame like that
headline will come someday there is no
stopping it
the best defense is to ensure that we
have an open local community driven
application that everybody wants first
otherwise if you think the hole we're in
thanks to how Agri biotech has been
conducted to date is deep just wait the
other way to defend is to come up with a
technological way of restoring any
engineered population to wild-type that
is to say it doesn't matter if somebody
screws up you are going to have genetic
vandalism into wild populations we have
to be able to fix it and one of the neat
things about Daisy quorum is that it
lets you do something where in supposing
someone does screw up and releases even
an invasive global gene drive system you
drop in a few Daisy quorums engineered
so that it spreads like a like a
self-sustaining drive using you only in
the presence of the rogue nuclease it
will override all copies switch over to
Daisy when in the wild-type you end up
with this population that's all
engineered with the Daisy quorum so
you're blocking gene flow further gene
flow between here and out then if you
just drop in enough wild-type so these
are now in the minority or use CRISPR
suppression to suppress all of the
organism engineer organisms that have
CRISPR as soon as these guys are back in
the minority the quorum wipes them out
that is every engineered gene is gone
because every engineered gene in that
population has become linked to the
quorum effect and the quorum effect says
that if you're in the minority that
you're outvoted and you're going away so
the entire population returns to
wild-type no matter what the engineered
gene is and that's the that's our goal
for this restore any at least
amenable engineered population to
wild-type no matter what anybody else
did with it
that means there's lots of different
things that we could potentially do if
we can actually efficiently alter a
specific local wild population with any
consenting community without affecting
any others namely health animal welfare
environment and agriculture and again
this must not come first but these
others are interesting and this is an
extension of the original Venn diagram I
drew in our Elife paper describing
CRISPR gene drives that one didn't have
animal welfare but it's one that I've
been thinking about a lot more and I
decided to put an opposite environment
because there's going to be an
interesting moral tension that we're
going to have to face that is are we
obligated to intervene Peter singers
famous drowning child example says well
if you're willing to jump into a lake to
save a drowning child and thereby
ruining your shoes and suit then why
aren't you willing to give a
corresponding amount of money to save a
child on the other side of the world I
would say this is an interesting case
because if you have a the child's in a
deep lake you are responsible for
jumping in and saving the child think
most people would agree you don't have
to have pushed the child in but if
you're the one who could save them then
you are obligated to do so but only if
you already know how to swim no one
would ask you to probably throw away
your life and also fail to save the
child if you don't know how to swim we
don't expect you to jump in a deep lake
to save a drowning child well here's the
thing right now animals are suffering in
nature and with these technologies we
are actively learning how to swim
we didn't make those animals suffer
that's just how evolution works
evolution has no moral compass evolution
doesn't care
nature is not immoral but it is a moral
but we are moral creatures and as soon
as we gain the power to intervene the
power to do something about it then we
are morally responsible whatever
decision we make that is to say we are
going to have to face the fact that
animal welfare concerns are going to
oppose those of a sacredness of nature
concerns they are in direct opposition
you cannot simultaneously have a
completely wild pristine population of
organisms and the absence of animal
suffering because that's inherent to it
so what are we going to do in some cases
it's pretty egregious this is a this is
the key deer and the Florida Keys there
was recently an outbreak of New World
screwer in which we had previously
pushed all the way down to South America
using sterile insect technique there's
about a thousand of these deer and about
and as of October 83 of them had died of
screwworm this is commonly considered to
be one of the most excruciating ly
agonizing afflictions ever known because
it doesn't affect afflict people if you
have something as small as a tick bite
then a screw rim fly can get in there
and lay its eggs and they will eat their
way out and they like nervous tissue in
particular this organism cannot but live
save through causing horrific agony to
higher mammals that is those organisms
that we deemed to have what it the close
being closest to being conscious and the
greatest ability to suffer pain what are
we going to do because this is a species
that we could if we wanted to it's only
now in South America and occasionally
invades back we could remove it from the
wild entirely and only propagate it so
that it does not go extinct in a
laboratory on already killed animals if
we wanted to if we don't then the agony
of every animal infested with screw or
implies is on our heads so
it's our responsibility what are we
going to do thanks to my group in
particular for taking risks because
again I'm at the Media Lab the
incentives are different for me that
their careers really are on the line so
they're the true heroes for agreeing to
join and make all of their best ideas
open and to all of our collaborators for
work that okay to be fair most of which
is not actually presented in this
presentation and thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
[Music]